Im Schnee der Antarktis haben Münchner Forschende
etwas gefunden, das nicht aus unserem Sonnensystem
stammt.
Konkret geht es um das Isotop Eisen-60, das
keine natürlichen Quellen auf der Erde hat.
Ist es vielleicht durch eine Supernova auf
unseren Heimatplaneten gelangt?
Es ist auf jeden Fall unglaublich spektakulär,
denn wenn es im Schnee gefunden wurde, dann
ist es erst vor ganz ganz kurzer Zeit auf
die Erde gelangt.
Was ist da passiert?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Schon 2015 nahm die ganze spektakuläre Story
ihren Lauf: Damals hatte das Forschungsteam
von der TU München und dem Alfred-Wegener-Institut
viel zu tun.
Nahe der Kohnen-Station, eine deutsche polare
Forschungsstation in der Antarktis, sollte
eine halbe Tonne Schnee geschippt werden.
Natürlich alles für die Wissenschaft!
Insgesamt 25 Kisten - voll mit Schnee - machten
sich damals dann auf eine lange Reise.
Zunächst mit dem Flugzeug an die antarktische
Küste.
Dann ging es weiter mit dem Schiff nach Kapstadt
und dann schlussendlich nach München.
Der Schnee wurde dort geschmolzen und genauer
analysiert.
Und der Plan von Gunther Korschinek ging tatsächlich
auf.
Der Physiker hatte darauf spekuliert, dass
in dem Antarktis-Schnee ein spektakulärer
Fund gemacht werden könnte.
Denn schon vor 20 Jahren gelang dem Wissenschaftler
von der TU München der Nachweis des Isotops
Eisen-60 in Tiefsee-Ablagerungen.
Schon damals stand die Vermutung im Raum,
dass dieser Fund von Eisen-60 in einer Mangankruste
der Tiefsee auf eine Supernovae hinweisen
könnte.
Diese habe möglicherweise vor rund zwei Millionen
Jahren in der Nähe unseres Sonnensystems
stattgefunden.
Und auch im reinen Schnee der Antarktis malte
Korschinek sich gute Chancen aus, weitere
Eisen-60-Ablagerungen zu finden.
Anders als in anderen Regionen dieser Erde,
denn der feine Staub des Kosmos geht gewöhnlich
in der Natur unter.
Das radioaktive Isotop Eisen-60 ist - genauso
wie fast alle anderen chemischen Elemente,
die uns bekannt sind - einst im Inneren von
Sternen oder bei einer Sternexplosion entstanden.
Doch dieses Isotop ist sehr selten und instabil.
Es hat eine Halbwertszeit von 2,62 Millionen
Jahren.
Das heißt, dass sich seine ursprünglich
vorhandene Menge alle 2,6 Millionen Jahre
halbiert.
Klar ist also: Wenn vor 4,6 Milliarden Jahren
- als die Erde entstanden ist - Eisen-60 vorhanden
gewesen sein sollte, muss es bis heute vollständig
zerfallen sein.
Gelingt der Nachweis auf der Erde, ist somit
klar, dass es vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
aus dem Weltraum gekommen sein muss.
“Vor nicht zu langer Zeit” - das ist natürlich
in astronomischen Dimensionen gemeint.
Korschinek sollte mit seiner Vermutung, was
den Antarktis Schnee angeht, Recht behalten.
Bei den Analysen im Labor ließen sich in
den Proben fünf Teilchen des seltenen Eisen-60-Isotops
nachweisen.
Eine Premiere, denn bislang konnte dieses
Isotop noch niemals in einer Schneeprobe aufgespürt
werden.
Eine super spannende und verantwortungsvolle
Arbeit, die dafür notwendig war.
Dazu die Wissenschaftlerin Silke Merchel,
die an der chemischen Analyse beteiligt war:
“Ich habe vorher mit leeren Filtern geübt,
damit bei der endgültigen Arbeit mit der
wertvollen Probe nichts schiefgeht.
Außerdem habe ich geschaut, welche Elemente
in den Filtern und verwendeten Chemikalien
schon drin sind, denn die späteren Messungen
waren so empfindlich, dass man damit alles
findet."
Die genaue Analyse zeigte, dass das aufgespürte
Isotop mit sehr großer Sicherheit aus einer
Supernova-Explosion stammt.
Weder Atomwaffen-Tests noch die sekundäre
Einwirkung kosmischer Strahlung kommen nach
Angabe des Forschungsteam als mögliche Quellen
in Frage.
Doch die Fachleute wissen sogar noch mehr:
Denn dadurch, dass der Schnee aus der Antarktis
nicht älter als 20 Jahre alt ist, müssen
diese Relikte einer Supernova erst vor kurzer
Zeit auf die Erde niedergegangen sein.
Die Sternenexplosion wird höchstwahrscheinlich
sogar in unserer kosmischen Nachbarschaft
stattgefunden haben, denn sonst wäre der
Staub aus Eisen-60 stärker verdünnt - und
somit kaum noch in nachweisbarer Menge auf
der Erde aufzuspüren.
Nach Ansicht der Fachleute handelt es sich
bei der Quelle dieser Eisen-60-Partikel höchstwahrscheinlich
um eine der interstellaren Gaswolken, durch
die wir mit unserem Sonnensystem derzeit hindurchfliegen.
Dazu Gunter Korschinek: “Unser Sonnensystem
ist vor etwa 40.000 Jahren in eine dieser
Wolken eingetreten und wird sie in einigen
tausend Jahren wieder verlassen.
Ideal wäre natürlich, wenn wir den Übergang
des Sonnensystems in diese Wolke hinein nachweisen
könnten.".
Eine Wolke in unserer direkten Nähe ist die
sogenannte “Local Interstellar Cloud”;
die durch eine Supernovae entstanden sein
könnte.
Doch diese Vermutung kann erst durch weitere
Untersuchungen mit letzter Sicherheit bestätigt
werden.
Das spezielle Eisen-60-Isotop dürfte dann
nämlich erst in Eisschichten der Antarktis
auftauchen, die jünger sind als 40.000 Jahre.
Was die aktuelle Untersuchung aber sehr deutlich
macht: Auch in unserer kosmischen Nachbarschaft
haben Explosionen von Sternen stattgefunden.
Und dies kann somit auch in Zukunft immer
mal wieder geschehen.
Auch Funde von Eisen-60 in Fossilien und Gesteinsschichten
legen übrigens nahe, dass vor etwa 2,6 Millionen
Jahren eine Supernova stattgefunden haben
muss - und zwar in nur 150 Lichtjahren Entfernung
von der Erde.
Möglicherweise ist sogar unser Sonnensystem
durch eine nahe Sternexplosion entstanden.
Wann sehen wir eine Supernova mit bloßem
Auge am Himmel?
Gute Frage.
Anklicken, anschaeun und Neugerizone abonnieren.
Ich bin auf die Antwort wirklich gespannt.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!